[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wait
[Music]
do
[Music]
part
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
like I
child
my
[Music]
okay
see
[Music]
okay all right I hope you enjoyed this
video so I mean let's take a break once
I'm gonna drink oh it's a coca-cola yeah
sure do you want a glass let's go get a
glass all right one this vehicle is
sponsored by brilliant dot org I did not
expect that anyways I will continue the
video after this message
by the way this video was sponsored by
brilliant org which is kind of cool
because I actually used trillion org
when I was applying to my untitled large
company since the company gave me links
to help me prepare for my interview and
one of the links that they gave me is a
bunch of combinatorics questions
aka probability questions on brilliant
org it really helped me on the math part
of the interview because I was killing
the probability questions I actually
find it really fun to crank out these
questions it makes me feel good about
myself and keeps me sharp and they're
good brain teasers for interviews
especially for data science or quantity
very good supplement to my interview
preps so highly recommended also if
you're in school you can supplement your
learning by using this website because
there's a wide variety of topics which
is pre-built because I love the UI on
the website and it makes studying so
much more fun with their quizzes if
you're interested there's a link in the
description down below best of all you
can get 20% off their premium
subscription so you too you can kill it
at the interview for the large and type
of company alright thanks for watching
this video if you liked it don't forget
to Like and subscribe and I also want to
shout out to Jared thank you for
supporting this channel and we got one
question from honey what do you do
during weekends well I do a lot of stuff
I film and then I edit my video
sometimes I
Matt Cho I'd like to try any restaurants
I like to go to the gym that's pretty
fun I do a little bit of rock climbing
and then if it's during the winter I go
snowboarding so yeah that's pretty much
it thanks for watching and
[Music]
[Laughter]